now first witness is Constantine Kissin
who's a russian-born satirist podcaster
commentator author of an immigrant love
letter to the West
um you're in love with us because of our
Notions of individual Freedom which by
the way you think we've been dangerously
complacent about why is individual
Freedom so much more important than
Collective Freedom security Prosperity
well-being it's a Bedrock of the success
of the West it's the very thing that
defines Western Civilization against all
others and we've had we talk always
about it as a word the easiest way to
understand freedom is to experience a
lack of it I grew up in the late Soviet
Union with stories of my parents and
grandparents being sent to the gulag for
things that they said or decisions they
made and so I think the easiest way to
understand freedom is to understand what
it's like not to have it and that's
where my concern about the direction
we're traveling in now comes from
because we're in a position where we
punish people for the things that they
say and we do this because we've
conflated words and speech with physical
actions like violence and this is quite
deliberate swapping of meaning in my
opinion which then allows people to
suppress opinions that they don't like
in order to advance their own cause
if I were to LEAP across the stage and
Tackle you to the ground that would be
an unacceptable curtailment of your
freedom it's quite enjoyable though but
yeah so
very good money
let's say you're you're in a violent
frenzy you were chucking chairs around
it would be acceptable for me to tell
your freedom in order to prevent harm to
others
yes right so let's take a more passive
example let's say I have a fridge full
of food and you are starving and I don't
want to give it to you should we be able
to curtail my property rights in order
that you might have the right to live
the freedom to live
so you want to take someone else's
property in order to execute your belief
in what I'm saying I'm saying you are
starving and I've got a fridge full of
food yes and I don't want to give it to
you someone be able to make me give it
to you no no even though you would die
yes you would starve to death yes
because I believe in property rights do
you have a front door in your house I do
have there are people who are homeless
why don't you let them into your home I
would say that property rights can and
should be curtailed in order that others
might so someone might freeze to death
should they be forcefully entered into
someone was freezing to death in my door
I would have a moral duty to let them in
the moral duty is a different thing
you're talking about compelling someone
through violence right you're
threatening somebody with violence for
not doing something you don't want done
so it's always violent to compel someone
to share
but how
how meaningfully be free if you are
starving to death how can a Hungry Man
meaningfully be said to have freedom I
don't understand what is the lack of
Freedom there if you're starving how are
you free
if you're starving how are you on free
because you cannot exercise your
freedoms you cannot participate in a
community of people you cannot exercise
your political rights because you are
dying so Freedom means being able to do
things because other people have
provided them for you is that what you
mean I'm saying that freedom means that
you are able to act on your human
capacity for a reason for critical
engagement to participate in a political
community and you can't do that if it's
a very strange argument as someone who
slept in a park for weeks and did go
hungry I don't think I felt any less
free I was just hungry these are
different things you you think that that
it's possible to participate as a
meaningful political agent if you are
on the verge of death I mean I'll be
honest with you when I was going hungry
and sleeping in a park participating in
the political system wasn't my main
priority but
I didn't feel unfree I felt poor and
hungry and homeless
this is not connected to freedom in any
way well let's let's what you're talking
about is you want to enforce on other
people your wishes on how they should
act in relation to property that they've
accumulated right that's what you you
want the power to tell other people what
to do with their property